bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de Parlement Hebdo en compagnie cette
semaine de Delphine Girard bonjour
Delphine bonjour nous voici partis pour
un tour en 45 minutes de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
marqué bien sûr par les manifestations
en Égypte qui tournent à l'affrontement
entre pro et antiubarak le président
égyptien annonce son départ pour
septembre sans calmer la rue les
États-Unis et l'Europe réclament un
processus de transition immédiat et puis
les nouveaux embarras de Michel
aliionarie la ministre des Affaires
étrangères à qui l'on reproche d'avoir
utilisé l'avion privé d'un proche du
clan Benali lors de ses vacances de Noël
en Tunisie la ministre se dit meurtrie
par ses attaques enfin zoom sur un débat
écolo qui tourne à la polémique
politique le gage chisteux peut-être une
mine énergétique du futur mais très
polluant pour les Naves fréatiques le
débat a fait son entrée cette semaine
dans
l'hémicycle et avec nous pour commenter
l'actualité de cette semaine Yv coché
bonjour député de Paris alors vous
faites partie des quatre députés Verts
de l'Assemblée nationale et puis vous
êtes bien sûr l'un des deux candidats
déclarés pour les primaires du parti
écologiste pour 2012 sauf si Nicolas
HULLOT se présente et vous nous direz
vous nous direz justement s'il en a
vraiment envie et puis vous pourrez
d'autant plus nous en parler que vous
êtes un habitué des primaires hein vous
étiez déjà était le candidat malheureux
des primaires en 2007 face à Dominique
Benet vous vous en souvenez évidemment
et puis vous nous direz aussi dans cette
émission pourquoi vous avez interpellé
aussi vigoureusement dans l'hémicycle
Michel liomarie à propos de ses vacances
en Tunisie on y vient allez on passe
tout de suite en revue l'actualité de la
semaine avec vous Yve cocher et on en
sait désormais un peu plus sur le
calendrier des primaires chez récologie
les
vers c'est à hos que que le Conseil
fédéral d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
s'est réuni dimanche pour statuer sur la
désignation du candidat à la
présidentielle le vainqueur sera déclaré
le 24 juin ou le 9 juillet en cas de
second tour deux candidats à la primaire
sont déjà déclarés eva jolie et vous Yve
cocher quant à l'homme providentiel de
ses primaires Nicolas HULLOT il
réfléchit à se présenter et devrait
faire connaître sa décision d'ici avril
Jérémy Hartman il n'était pas là mais
tous ne parlaient que de lui l'ombre de
Nicolas HULLOT plané samedi sur le
Conseil fédéral d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts l'animateur télé doit annoncer
d'ici avril s'il se lance dans la
présidentiel en attendant on
s'impatiente un peu chez les écolos à
commencé par sa principale concurrente
déclarée honnêtement je ne pense pas à
nicolaso tous les jours je pense à à
nous à ce que nous devons faire au
progrès
encore pédagogique au programme à
construire Eva Jie pression sur Nicolas
hullo pour qu'il participe au primaire
du parti l'ancienne juge d'instruction
se dit déterminé à aller jusqu'au bout
mais difficile d'organiser une élection
interne sans la candidature officielle
d'un des favoris je peux pas comparer
une candidate déterminée officiellement
candidate et un non candidat on ne peut
pas nous attendre la décision de de
quelqu'un même d'ussi illustre que
Nicolas ici on le surnomme déjà le DSK
des écolos et c'est donc sans lui qu'ont
été fixés les des primaires elles auront
lieu fin juin les partisans de Nicolas
Hul auraient préféré septembre alors à
la tribune Daniel conbendit tente de
satisfaire tout le monde les deux
candidats déclarés et les autres demain
une trè personne se déclare prête à être
candidat candidate et bien il faudra
d'une manière sereine essayer de trouver
la solution pour avoir la meilleure
candidature IR pas chez Europe Écologie
tout le monde est suspendu à la décision
de Nicolas HULLOT la clôture des
candidatures est fixée au 15 mai alors
vous êtes candidat mais vous avez dit
que vous étiez prêt à vous retirer à
retirer votre candidature si Nicolas
HULLOT se présentait est-ce que ça
brouille pas un peu votre image non je
suis candidat puisque pour le moment il
y en a deux avec Madame jolie et il y a
une sorte de calendrier officiel de
méthode encore qu'on puisse y revenir
parce que ça a été adopté dans des
conditions disons douteuses et puis je
con évidemment Nicolas HULLOT on a déjà
parlé ensemble et depuis 6 mois je dis
que si jamais il a était candidat on le
sera dans à peu près 2 mois et bien je
me retiraai parce que je pense que c'est
lui le meilleur tout simplement selon
différents critères enfin le meilleur
pour avoir le meilleur score tout
simplement qui est quand même le
meilleur critère au moment où on fait
les élections présidentielles il a envie
d'y aller envie alors oui il a envie le
problème c'est qu' il est actuellement à
la tête de quelques PME on peut dire il
y a sa fondation la Fondation Nicolas
Hulot une trentaine de personnes il y a
également ses émissions sur TF1 au Chaya
bon donc il doit évidemment voir de
quelle manière ces gens-là survivront à
l'après Hulo au moins de ce point de
vue-là bon il y avait également sa
famille qui était un peu rétissante ça
s'est levé il y a également une
préparation un peu politique
psychologique hein il s'était déjà
préparé vous vous souvenez en 2006 2007
il avait dit est-ce que j'y vais j'y
vais pas ça avait duré assez longtemps
lui avait dit écout il avait pas un peu
plombé d'ailleurs déjà les primaires à
l'époque c'est ce qu'elle laissait
entendre Cécile Duflot oui bah il est
certain que c'est pas tellement les
primaires parce qu'on avait déjà une
candidature mais mais c'est peut-être la
campagne de madame qui avait été un peu
difficulteuse justement parce qu'on
attendait Hulo puis qu'il est pas allé
alors bien sûr elle avait signé comme
les autres le PACT écologique qui était
déjà un bon projet politique pour
l'écologie et pour la France là je pense
qu'il va pas le refaire d'ailleurs il a
dit c'est dans de mois disons début
avril qu'il le fera et donc un an avant
l'élection on SAA si oui il y va ou si
non il y va pas s'il y va pas bah il y
aura des candidatures comme Madame jolie
comme moi peut-être d'autres et s'il y
va moi je me retirrais et je pense qu'à
ce moment-là peut-être que evolie qui
dit évidemment vous Laer jusqu'au bout
moi aussi mais peut-être seraittir
rt-elle simplement parce que il y aura
une sorte de vague Hulot et il sera
clair pour tout le monde que c'est le
candidat on pourrait dire naturel de
l'Éc vous avez vu ce qu'a ditolen Royal
être Président c'est pas comme porter
une émission de télé oui oui j'ai j'ai
vu ça je crois que c'était hier enfin
bon je dis en effet au moment d'une
visite en scène Sam mais il est vrai
elle a raison que une une une
présidentielle la politique c'est pas la
même chose que l'émission de télé mais
je dirais que Nicolas c'est pas la même
chose que Patrick Sébastien et que lui
il aura avec lui tous les militants de
l'écologie politique d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts il aura aussi une préparation
qu'il a déjà fait je le dis en 2007 il
avait écrit un livre qui était déjà très
politique il connaît bien les politiques
ceux qui existent on dit quelquefis oui
mais il est quand même un petit peu à
droite parce que il est copain non il
l'est pas moi il m'a dit si ça avait été
par exemple lonel juspin qui avait été
élu en 2002 bah il se sera adressé à
Lionel Jospin simplement ça a été de
nouveau Chirac puis ensuite sarzi il
s'adresse en tant qu'ONG en tant
qu'association au pouvoir en place un
peu comme Monsieur Bernard tibaau de la
CGT bah il discute avec le ministre du
Travail et quel qu'il soit bon par
contre si jamais et comme je le souhaite
dans 2 mois il bascule et qu'il vraiment
il change sa vie il vient avec nous dans
le camp politique je pense qu'il sera
prêt il a déjà assez souvent des
séminaires de travail pas simplement sur
l'écologie biophysique parce que ça il
connaît ça mais sur sur les relations
internationales sur la dette de l'État
sur le budget de la France sur le
chômage sur les retraites enfin et donc
il élargit considérablement et là on
fait quoi on arrête les primeures on
fait quoi moi je le souhaiterais la
preuve c'est que je me retirrais bon il
faut voir si EV jolie pas forcément
d'accord non elle sera pas forcément
d'accord mais comme tout le monde n'est
pas forcément d'accord avec le fait que
elle a vraiment percé dans les sondages
et même dans l'opinion publique quand
même d'écologiste de la dernière pluie
ça n'est pas très gentil non plus dis ça
oui ah c'est ce qui était écrit
non ce que j'ai dû dire ça je je le je
le confirme c'est que Evva jolie elle le
dit elle-même est assez nouvelle en
politique et assez nouvelle en écologie
ça fait quoi moins de 2 ans et donc on
peut pas dire qu'aux yeux de nos
concitoyens parce que c'est les citoyens
qui votent finalement pas les militants
ah EV va c'est l'écologiste historique
qu'on a toujours connu non ça elle
pourra pas le faire même si elle a des
grandes capacités pour apprendre et pour
parler de tas de choses allez lundi
toujours Jacques Chirac se porte bien
c'est lui-même qui l'affirme a des
journalistes qui l'interrogent dans la
rue après des rumeurs de maladie
d'Alzheimer en ce lundi on apprend aussi
que la date de son procès sur les emploi
présumé fictif de la ville de Paris est
toujours maintenu au 7 mars Kamal abdim
aux caméras qu'il attend devant son
domicile jaces shirac n'a qu'une chose à
dire il va bien écoutez est-ce que j'ai
je vous donne l'impression de ne pas
aller bien non non je ne sais pas je POS
la question je me porte très bien je
vous remercie l'ancien chef de l'État
réagit aux rumeurs qui le dit atteint de
la maladie d'alizheimer une théorie que
son épouse avait démenti un peu plus tôt
dans la journée les médecins lui ont dit
qu'il n'a pas la maladie d'Alzheimer je
les crois il a toujours dit qu'il
voulait être traité comme injusticiable
comme un autre et il a dit qu'il irait à
son procès et il le fera le procès des
emplois fictifs un procès historique
prévu début mars mais pas question
d'évoquer des problèmes de santé
illustration avec un soutien socialiste
le corésien François Hollande qui parle
d'un homme toujours aussi cohérent il a
son âge il a connu ses s ennui de santé
et alors
laissons-le dire ce qu'il a à dire
montrer ce qu'il a à montrer et ne
faisons pas là l' espèce d'utilisation
d'une faiblesse possible l'ancien chef
d'État est poursuivi pour détournement
de fond public abus de confiance et
prise illégale d'intérêt il risque 10
ans de prison et 150 500 € d'amende
alors y cocher on sait que la mairie de
Paris a trouvé un accord avec Jacques
Chirac un accord financier l'association
Anticor demande l'annulation de cet
accord on va bien voir ce que ce que ce
que dira le tribunal les vers au Conseil
de Paris étaient farouchement opposés à
cette accord ils le sont toujours ils le
sont toujours oui nous pensons que ça
ressemble beaucoup à un accord entre
amis en disant on va chinter la justice
il y a eu évidemment un préjudice
financier avec ces emplois fictifs et
bien on va s'arranger qui a été
remboursé hein donc 1 million remboursé
plus ou moins plus ou moins et alors
d'autant plus que c'était le RPR c'est
l'UMP une partie c'est quand même le
président Chirac lui-même enfin tout ça
ressemble à quelque chose qui consiste à
ne pas dire la vérité sur ce qui s'est
passé vraiment alors qu'il y a des gens
qui ont déjà été condamnés pour cela et
donc qu' aura pas de partie civile hein
c'est c'est ça qui
éta c'est un peu ennuyeux c'est un peu
ennuyeux enfin parce que c'est
absolument scandaleux si c'est avéré
comme d'ailleurs ça l'a été pour
d'autres personnes souvenez-vous que
monsieur Jupé qui est maintenant au
gouvernement a quand même été condamné
du temps où ils étaient tous à la mairie
de Paris donc moi je peux pas je peux
pas imaginer que Monsieur Chirac n'ait
pas été au courant de tout ça bon on
verra j'espère que le procès aura lieu
qu'il viendra il a l'air de dire oui je
ne me déroberit pas à la justice qu'il
répondra qu'il n'aura pas de pre de
mémoire et qu'on SAA enfin la vérité
dont je soupçonne qu'elle est celle
qu'on sait déjà al justement s'il
s'affiche en bonne santé il prend
également le risque d'être entendu dans
d'autres affaires c'est quand même
courage pour de la part de son entourage
de le présenter comme ça en bonne santé
ben c'est pas courageux si c'est réel
puisque ce sont des médecins d'après
Madame Chirac elle-même qui ont jugé que
il est cert un peu fatigué parce qu'il
est pas de tout jeune âge mais qu'il a
encore tous les moyens de répondre de se
déplacer et cetera il est normal que
d'abord ce procès lu début mars puis
ensuite d'autres affaires il soi jugé
nous nous sommes en plus contre toutes
les juridiction d'exception on pourrait
parler de l'affaire Bur puisque il est
possible qu'un jour aussi il y ait
disons la Cour de Justice de la
République qui est un tribunal
d'exception nous on veut le droit commun
pour tout le monde notamment les gens
qui ne sont plus en fonction comme le
président ou l'ex- président Chirac donc
dans ce cas-là si elle doit répondre
devant la justice et s'il est finalement
coupable de quelque chose et bien il
doit payer enfinant plus que le
président Chirac disons a bien profité
de la République depuis toujours il n'a
jamais vraiment travaillé à l'extérieur
des institutions il doit aussi être
auditionné éventuellement par dans
l'affaire carachiste en tout cas les
familles qui le demandent également dans
l'angolagette vous pensez qu'il faut
comme ça sortir toutes les affaires sur
un président vieillissant ou comme
certains vous comprenez qu'on puisse
dire bon peut-être peut-être on peut le
laisser un peu qu'en pensez-vous non non
je ne le pense pas je je vous le dis je
crois que en effet comment vous le voyez
vous le dites vous-même il y a beaucoup
d'affaires disons qui concernent
l'exprésident Chirac que à chaque fois
c'est quand même une question de
responsabilité politique aussi bien en
tant que maire de Paris en tant que à
l'époque président du RPR ou bien en
effet disant Premier ministre puis
président de la République il faut
vraiment que dans toutes ces affaires
une par une et spécifiquement bien
entendu regarder quelle fut sa
responsabilité et si elle est engagée au
sens qu'il est reconnu coupable et bien
il doit avoir une peine comme n'importe
quelle justiciable très bien on passe à
la journée du mardi l'Égypte en pleine
confusion plus d'un million de personnes
réunies au C place tarir et dans
plusieurs villes d'Égypte mardi du
jamais vu pour réclamer le départ d'osni
Mbarak dans la soirée celui-ci annonce
qu'il ne sera pas candidat à la
prochaine présidentielle alors que les
États-Unis appellent à une transition
rapide Mathilde
terrier aujourd'hui le président
égyptien a peut-être perdu un de ses
derniers alliés Barack
Obama ce n'est le rôle d'aucun autre
pays de choisir les dirigeants égyptiens
seul les Égyptiens peuvent le faire et
ce qui est clair ce que j'ai dit ce soir
au président Mbarak c'est qu'une
transition ordonnée doit être entière
elle doit se dérouler pacifiquement et
elle doit commencer maintenant un coup
de fil de la Maison Blanche qui presse
le pas de Mbarak vers la sortie passé 2
he seulement après le discours du
dictateur à la
télévision je vous le dis en toute
sincérité en dehors des circonstances
actuelles je n'avais aucune intention de
me présenter pour de nouvelles
élections le président ne renouvellera
pas son mandat mais entend toutefois
gouverner jusqu'en septembre chez les
manifestants c'est la stupéfaction une
ultime provocation à la fin d'une
journée test sans précédent avec le
Paris pourtant gagné d'une marche de
plus d'un million de personnes Auer et à
Alexandrie le plus important pour nous
c'est qu'il doit partir aujourd'hui pas
demain pas la semaine prochaine pas pour
les prochaines
élections vendredi prochain on se
dirigera vers son palais d'helliopolis
et on le sortira ultimatum lancé avant
ce discours par Mohamed El baradaï prix
nomEl de la paix aujourd'hui leader
principal de la contestation du côté des
diplomatie auilte en presse après avoir
longtemps été en retrait plus que modéré
Nicolas Sarkozi sort de son silence et
souhaite que la transition s'engage
chantardé acculé seul contre son peuple
et contre la majorité de la communauté
internationale le sort deosni Mubarak
semble désormais scellé reste à savoir
combien de temps ils va le supporter
alors aujourd'hui est-ce que osni
Mubarak peut encore rester jusqu'à la
prochaine élection présidentielle il a
déclaré jeudi à la télévision américaine
qu'il ne pouvait pas laisser le pouvoir
en place il ne pouvait pas laisser le
pays dans dans le chaos alors euh moi je
n'ai pas l'information supplémentaire à
celle que tout le monde peut avoir en
France mais j'entends ce que disent
disons les diplomaties et même les chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement de différents
pays et je trouve remarquable que dans
le cas de la Tunisie comme dans le cas
de l'Égypte le président Obama est réagi
rapidement et en très peu de mots
une quarantaine de mots a suffit pour
dire quelle est la posture des
États-Unis en gros c'était d'essayer
d'avoir une transition now a-t-il dit en
anglais c'est-à-dire maintenant et donc
ça ne peut pas être au mois de septembre
comme était la date disons des
prochaines présidentielles ça peut être
une transition pardon avec ou sans osni
Mubarak puisque il parle déjà de
transition oui mais une transition ça ça
peut être surtout sans osni Mubarak car
je crois que le président Obama a bien
jugé peut-être quelques autres aussi en
Europe que le le le peuple de manière un
peu symbolique réclame le départ de
Mbarak dans la mesure où il représente
l'ensemble disons de cette dictature il
faut bien le dire depuis une trentaine
d'années donc c'est la même chose que
benalii en Tunisie il y a évidemment des
changements réels qui doivent avoir lieu
le gouvernement les les les question à
la fois de canal de suess de pétrole des
meutes de la fin car il y a aussi le
prix disons des œufs du lait de de de la
viande de la farine de l'huile qui
augmente c'est aussi ça la révolte du
peuple égyptien il y a pas uniquement la
question institutionnelle il y y a tout
qui se mélange mais je crois que ça doit
se faire en effet maintenant
c'est-à-dire dans les jours et semaines
qui viennent est-ce que l'Europe n'a pas
un peu tardé et la France à réagir bah
une fois de plus on connaît les la
politique arabe de la France depuis le
général de Gaulle qui était une bonne
politique il semble que on y soit resté
au sens que madame aliomarie est d'une
manière générale même monsieur couchner
jadis n'est pas vu qu'il y avait des
évolutions très fortes notamment
d'aspiration
et qu'il fallait au moins par
l'intermédière de nos ambassades
discuter avec les opposants et avec les
comités disons du du peuple il ça sont
ils ont une espèce de de
postureons déférentielle vis-à-vis des
dictateurs je crois que c'est fini et
notre diplomatie et les chefs de notre
diplomatie ont failli en ce sens allez
mardi toujours la réponse du
gouvernement au meurtre de laetia en
Loire Atlantique les ministres de
l'Intérieur et de la justice pointent
une défaillance de la chaîne pénale et
annonce une série de mesures dont la
création d'un office de suivi des
délinquants sexuels et violents le
ministre de l'Intérieur bris sortefeu y
revient dans l'hémicycle on l'écoute
nous avons décidé l'inscription
automatique et immédiate sur le fichiier
des personnes recherchées d'un
délinquant qui ne satisferait pas ses
obligations nous avons décidé comme vous
l'avez voté et que ce sera bientôt
promulguée l'extension obligatoire du
port du bracelet électronique nous avons
aussi décidé la création d'un office
rassemblant les services de l'intérieur
de la justice et de la santé pour mieux
repérer et mieux anticiper les
délinquants alors c'est vrai que face à
la barbarie je vous le dis monsieur le
député bonec nous sommes totalement
déterminés et face à ces actes
monstrueux notre société n'est pas
impuissante alors on connaît la suite
jeudi Nicolas Sarkozi parle de grave
dysfonctionnement et promet des
sanctions dans la foulée les magistrats
donnant de vote une sorte de grève
puisque c'est une semaine sans audience
Nicolas Sarkozi a-t-il été injuste avec
la justice il l' a été pour des raisons
politiciennes parce que je crois que
c'est une sorte de début de campagne
enfin et ça fait très longtemps qu'il
est en campagne Nicolas Sarkozi et que
il remet là sur des éventuels débats de
2012 et bien la question sécurité la
question de la justice la question de la
gendarmerie et de la police la question
de la délinquence qui sont son frond de
commerce en essayant
disons de racoller un peu les voix
d'extrême droite puisque c'est comme ça
qu'il avait essayé disons de les réduire
en 2007 je crois que ça va recommencer
avec Marine Le Pen moi je crois que
c'est évidemment pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire il y a déjà d'ailleurs en 5 ans
non en 6 ans il y a eu déjà CIN lois qui
ont parlé de la délincrance et de la
récidive et de la récidive ça n'est pas
une loi supplémentaire évidemment qui va
satisfaire alors là c'est plutôt la
création d'un office bien sûr qu'il faut
que la justice notamment la justice mais
aussi la police et la gendarmerie a plus
de moyens mais appliquons plutôt les
lois avec des moyens supplémentaires
plutôt que de dire on va encore faire
une fuite en avant sur cette question
des moyens Michel alionarie a mis en
place la réserve judiciaire elle veut
faire Rael à des magistrats des
greffiers retraités c'est une bonne idée
ou c'est du colmatage oui non c'est du
colmatage je crois qu'il faut qu'il ait
vraiment des magistrats supplémentaires
des conditions également de détention
qui soi moins indignes que celle qu'on
voit dans notre République je sais pas
si vous avez visité les maisons d'arrêt
ou les prisons mais enfin la la moitié
d'entre elles sont vraiment très
délabrées insalubre enfin c'est c'est
indigne quoi et donc il faut un peu plus
d'argent pour le ministère de la Justice
tout simplement pour caler les moyens à
la fois de fonctionner pour rendre la
justice et également du côté
pénitentiaire d'avoir quelque chose de
décent pour les prisonniers il y a un
député UMP Richard maillet qui propose
que les maire soit mis dans le circuit
et et un pouvoir de contrôle ainsi on
les informerait sur la venue sur le le
commune d'un d'un condamné pour faits
graves c'est quoi ça c'est une double
peine ou c'est une solutionou il y a il
y a déjà avec le bracelet électronique
on peut dire la géolocalisation et tout
ce qui concerne la sécurité la
délinquance la justice doit rester du
pouvoir de l'État enfin c'est vraiment
le pouvoir régalien si bien il y en a un
en France et par conséquent ce sont les
moyens de la justice alors il fallait
peut-être pas fermer autant de tribunaux
fermer autant de commissariats là on
peut faire un débat budgétaire comme il
y en a eu d'ailleurs au Sénat à
l'Assemblée mais je pense pas que les
maires qui sont déjà officiers de police
judiciaire mais pour des raisons rapides
disons de rapidité ne doivent pas en
plus être les auxiliaires de justice je
ne crois pas alors mardi encore la
Fondation abaispierre interpelle les
politiques dans son rapport annuel elle
pointe la grave pénurie de logement plus
de 3 millions et demi de personnes sont
mal logées le rapport débusque aussi les
difficultés de ménages jusque-l épargné
comme des propriétaires modestes
incapables de faire face aux charges
Chloé Buffard
carton rouge contre le mallogement plus
de 10 millions de Français sont touchés
parmi eux
3600000 sont très mal logés c'est-à-dire
qu'ils vivent dans une cabane ou à
plusieurs dans une chambre d'hôtel et
33000 sont sans abri des chiffres qui ne
cessent d'augmenter car à cause de la
crise économique les classes moyennes
sont aussi concerné maintenant les
classes moyennes commencent à être
touché par par cette crise parce que
l'accession à la propriété devient
extrêmement difficile pour eux à cause
du la flambée des prix
et ils ont aussi du mal à se loger dans
le parc locatif puisque il y a très peu
de logements privés et ils sont très
chers la Fondation demande donc au
gouvernement plus de moyens elle estime
à 500000 le nombre de logements manquant
par an la Fondation demande une dépens
des pouvoirs publics de 2 % de PIB en
faveur du logement en 2010 on aura fait
1,96 record depuis
1986 25 ans que les aides publiques au
logement 25 ans et c'est un record battu
la Fondation abbépierre dénonce aussi la
politique du tous propriétaire voulu par
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007 les aides
fiscales seraient insuffisantes pour
aider les plus modestes à acheter et
certains propriétaires basculeraient
même dans le surendettement en face au
mallog que propose le candidat au
primair que vous êtes et bien je vois
que Nicolas Sarkozi et son gouvernement
propose tous propriétaires nous on le
dit pas on dit actuellement c'est plutôt
tous précaire et c'est donc la précarité
la précarité énergétique mais aussi
l'insalubrité et la difficulté de ce
d'une bonne intention quand même le tous
propriétaire le r dans d'utres pays
européens l'accession à la propriété
qu'on soit disons riche ou pauvre n'est
pas la politique principale on sa qu'en
France c'est une particularité française
on a envie d'être euh on a envie mais il
faut pouvoir l'être il faut pouvoir
rembourser on voit bien que dans les
commissions départementales de
surendettement il y a beaucoup de gens
qui n'ont pas pu honorer finalement leur
crédit donc faut faire très attention et
l'autre part c'est évidemment le rêve
des villes très étalées avec le pavillon
disons quelque part et puis le petit
jardin mais ça du point de vue
écologique alors c'est tout à fait
insoutenable notamment lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de transport en commun pour DESS
servir disons de manière assez dense et
rapide euh ce genre de lotissement donc
je crois qu'au contraire nous on est
favorable à des ville plus compacte ça
ne veut pas dire en hauteur ça ne veut
pas dire qu'ement il y ait pas l'espace
vert mais disons des petits collectifs
c'est mieux que soit des pavillons
individuels soit des trèon de tour donc
voilà au point de vue alors il y a
également il faut bien dire un
déséquilibre territorial et ça je le dis
parce que moi je suis franiliien
maintenant depuis une quinzaine d'années
mais auparavant j'étais breton c'est pas
du tout les mêmes prix ni la même
accession à la propriété ni les mêmes
loyers en Bretagne ou en île--france et
on veut toujours agrandir l'île-de-fance
il faut maîtriser vraiment la croissance
de l'île- de France pour pour dire non
il y a d'autres emplois il y a d'autres
manières de Vire je vois des
départements des région qui font de la
pub disant venez chez nous on n pas tous
les embouteillages toute la pollution
l'île-de-fance et on vit très bien et on
travaille très bien je crois qu'il faut
refaire de l'aménagement du territoire
qui a été un peu délaissé depuis 10 an
créer des pôles économiques attractifs
c'est c'est une politiqueou c'est ça
c'est ça mais tout de l'emploi n'est pas
en île-de-fance alors que l'île-de-fance
bénéficie ce soit pour la recherche
l'économie l'industrie on de beaucoup
plus de subventions que les autres
régions c'est dommage vous a vu soutenir
le quat de l'avenue matigon du collectif
Jeudi Noir est-ce que vous êt est-ce que
vous êtes pour la réquisition dé
logement vacan ah mais complètement il y
a une loi de réquisition à Paris bon les
chiffres sont difficiles mais enfin
c'est uniquement pour Paris on peut
estimer à 30000 le nombre d'appartements
ou logements qui sont vacan ce qui veut
dire à peu près 100000 personnes en
moyenne qui pourraent être logé s'il y
avait cette loi de réquisition qui
existe et qui qui était appliqué je suis
tout à fait favorable à ça allez on va
passer au mercredi et aux nouveaux
ennuis de Michel
aliomarie
elle avait déjà créé la polémique en
proposant l'aide de la France à la
police tunisienne cette fois ce sont ces
dernières vacances de Noël en Tunisie
qui font la Une selon le Canard Enchaîné
Michel aliomarie a utilisé le jet privé
d'un proche du clan Benali pour
rejoindre son lieu de vacances alors
qu'il y avait déjà les premiers troubles
dans le pays et c'est vous Yve Cochet on
va le voir qui êt monté au créneau dans
l'hémicycle juliaen le cororrec ce matin
à la sortie de l'Élysée premier démenti
devant les journalistes d'une ministre
qui traverse une zone de turbulence ce
monsieur est surtout une victime du clan
Benal il a été spolié par Monsieur
trabelski et d'ailleurs les choses sont
très claires puisque les Tunisiens
aujourd'hui l'ont ont réintroduit ce
monsieur dans ses droits en lui rendant
sa part de capitale et la présidence de
la Société voyez donc il y a absolument
Michel aliomarie et son compagnon ont
passé leurs vacances de Noël en Tunisie
à l'époque la révolution tunisienne
était déjà engagé plus grave les
révélations du Canard Enchaîné la chef
de la diplomatie française et son
compagnon aurait utilisé un jet privé
d'un homme d'affaires tunisien présenté
par le journal satirique comme un membre
du clan Ben Ali cet après-midi aux
questions au Gouvernement la ministre
est attaquée et sommé tout simplement de
démissionner je vous le dis je suis
indigné et révolté par vos paroles et
votre comportement et très amicalement
et sobrement je vous dis madame
partez sous le regard attentionné de son
compagnon lui aussi ministre et lui
aussi présent lors de leur voyage Michel
aliomarie se défend une nouvelle fois je
vous rappelle que si je prends mes
vacances parfois en Tunisie c'est àes
frais voyage et hôtel il n'a à aucun
moment mis son avion à ma disposition je
l'ai accompagné pendant 20 minutes de
trajet en avion une affaire de plus pour
une ministre au cœur des polémiques
depuis 2 mois Michel alionarie avait
déjà été critiqué pour une proposition
de coopération sécuritaire avec Tunis le
11 janvier alors la ministre s'est
expliqué à deux reprises depuis sur des
plateaux de télévision elle fait son
macoupa et le porte-parole du
gouvernement dit macoupa est fait et
maintenant on tourne la page la faire
clause oui le problème est que disons
depuis un mois et demi elle n'a cessé de
ne pas faire son m à coulep et de faire
ce qu'on peut appeler des erreurs même
des fautes politiques alors la première
était en effet après même le fait qu'il
y a eu un suicide monsieur boisizi là en
Tunisie donc une quinzaine de jours
après elle va comme si de rien nétait
alors qu'il y avait déjà des des disons
des rassemblements des émeutes et donc
des des aspirations à la Révolution et
pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas elle a dit
mais je suis un citoyen comme un autre
et je peux aller en vacances ce que je
veux c'est privé quand on est ministre
de la République même homme ou femme
politique en général on n'est pas un
citoyen comme un autre notamment quand
on représente la France à l'extérieur
donc c une première erreur la deuxième
erreur évidemment on l'a vu aussi c'est
lorsqu'elle a disons proposé l'aide
sécuritaire de la France à Ben al elle a
nié qui est disons du matériel qui a été
livré en fait il n'a pas été livré mais
le Premier ministre a avoué que quand
même il était prêt à être livré
plusieurs tonnes de grenades latrimogène
et enfin ce qui me paraît le plus
stupéfiant et inquiétant même c'est
qu'elle ne se rend pas compte de
l'impact de ses propos de son
comportement elle a l'air de dire que
c'est une petite affaire privée de rien
du tout et qu'il faut l'oublier non il
il y a vraiment dans l'opinion publique
et de manière internationale donc dans
l'image de la France quelque chose qui
s'est dégradé qui s'est disqualifié donc
je croit qu'elle elle devrait partir
mais apparemment le gouvernement et le
Premier ministre la défendre et bien il
y a qu'en France qu'on voit des choses
comme ça en Grande-Bretagne ou en
Allemagne je crois qu'elle serait partie
depuis très longtemps on peut qualifier
ça éventuellement de maladresse
non parce que vraiment erreur politique
c'est une erreur politique c'est ça
c'est pas une erreur de langage parce
que elle est quand même très habituée à
la langue de bois à la diplomatie ça
fait quand même 10 ans pratiquement
qu'elle est au gouvernement elle avait
déjà été avant donc elle maîtrise
totalement je crois que par exemple pour
l'aide disons sécuritaire à la Tunisie
bien vu un accord même du président de
la République donc c'est elle qui a été
au charbon pour l'expliquer enité c'est
un accord du gouvernement qui
globalement finalement a été aveugle à
si qui se passait un petit un peu comme
ils le sont actuellement pour l'Égypte
et et en plus alors elle-même donc avec
sa famille est allée en Tunisie au
moment de Noël il y il y a une
déréalisation facile de dire ça après
coup c'est que sur le moment elle le dit
elle-même il n'y avait pas encore de
répression
c'était il y avait déjà si si elle le
dit donc voilà souvenez-vous ça comm a
une ampleur avec le départ de Ben Ali et
les morts qu'on connaît en derrière mais
est-ce que à cette époque là à ce
momentlà on peut pas qualifier ça plus
de maladresse que réellement de fautes
politiques importantes je ne sais pas
quand on est ministre des Affaires
étrangères numéro 3 du gouvernement on
regarde surtout quand on voit que
quelque chose se passe à condition qu'on
le voit moi c'est c'est ça cette alors
moi j'appelle pas ça malraress j'appelle
ça erreur ou faute politique ça dépend
si on est du côté moral ou pas peu
importe c'est le fait qu'on ne voit pas
ce qui se passe une sorte d'aveuglement
à des événements qui était déjà sensible
depuis un certain temps moi je me
souviens on avait été en Tunisie il y a
2 ans avec un article qui avait été
évidemment à l'époque totalement
interdit qui s'appelle simplement
Tunisie verte et il nous avait dit oui
ça il y a c'est une dictature quand même
c'est une dictature un petit peu comme
hier il y a jeudi il y avait un débat à
l'Assemblée sur la création de l'IRENA à
Abou Dhabi he c'est l'Agence
internationale les énergies
renouvelables et moi j'ai critiqué je
n'ai même alors que j'adore les énergies
renouvelables en tant qu'écologiste mais
Aboud Dhabi c'est quand même une
dictature donc la France ne veut pas
soutir ça il y a des pays qui sont
devenus infréquentables bah alors vous
allez me dire les dictatures c'est la
moitié les pays de l'ONU donc il faut
savoir mais entre disons la la fermeté
et j'allais dire la lucidité du
président Obama et le flottement de la
diplomatie européenne notamment
française il y a une grosse différence
al mercredi toujours après les
proposition du rapport sauvé pour en
finir avec les conflits d'intérêts le
Sénat se penche à son tour sur les
incompatibilités de certaines
professions avec les mandats
parlementaires Gérard Larcher a chargé
la commission des Lois du Sénat de
préparer un code de bonne qui n'épargne
pas non plus les lobis Marie Bro le
Sénat souhaite afficher une image
irréprochable depuis un an et demi un
comité de déontologie réfléchit à
diverses améliorations en matière de
conflit d'intérêt et d'incompatibilité
parlementaire des conclusion remise
aujourd'hui au président du Sénat il
appartient à la Commission des lois le
moment venu de rendre publi ses
conclusions il y a un ordre des facteurs
et ensuite à la séance publique de de le
faire en matière de transparence totale
il va donc falloir attendre encore un
peu si le cas de quatre ou CIN sénateurs
semblent soulever la question de
l'incompatibilité il n'est pas question
pour le moment de dévoiler au grand
public les noms ou les situations
toutefois certaines mesures vont
s'appliquer pour contrôler l'accès du
Palais du Luxembourg au lobby ainsi les
représentants des centes de groupes
d'intérêt déclarés seront obligés de
porter un badge visible permettant de
les identifier en matière de
transparence
le Sénat veut ouvrir la voie surtout à
l'Assemblée nationale il m'a été demandé
de recouper avec l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'a pas la même procédure que nous
pour voir si l'analyse que nous faisons
l'intérieur du Sénat entre guillemets ne
serait pas contourné par l'autre
assemblée si les déplacements des
sénateurs à l'étranger financés par les
lobis doivent être déclarés cette
obligation ne s'applique pas au Palais
Bourbon Gérard Larcher va donc tenter de
convaincre bernardyet de faire jouer la
transparence alors est-ce qu'il faut
également que les députés déclarent leur
voyage quand ils sont financés par des
professionnels quand ils partent tout
frit payer bien sûr je crois que le
rapport de Monsieur sauvé est un bon
rapport en tout cas qui qui donne des
éléments de réflexion et qui serait bon
même qu'on puisse légiférer sur ce point
parce qu'il y a un flou en France alors
que dans d'autres pays c'est plus clair
par exemple au Parlement européen et
bien il y a des lobes mais on sait
exactement qui c'est ils ont pignon sur
rue et donc d'une certaine manière pas
simplement la transp mais la la
possibilité d'avoir des évidemment des
conversations entre les députés et puis
les forces économique en l'occurrence
est tout à fait clair au contraire en
France c'estén au assemblée c'est pas
clair il y a par exemple des assistants
parlementaires qui sont en fait payés
par les boîtes et puis il y a même des
gens qui ont d'une certain manière pas
double salaire ça c'est interdit enfin
qui travaillent encore dans leur propre
boîte alors ça c'est pas bon du tout il
en est de même d'ailleurs ce qu'on
appelle le pantouflage on l'a vu avec
Monsieur François Pérol par exemple qui
était des secrétaire général adjoint de
l'Élysée et qui a rejoint la Caisse
d'Épargne les Banques
Populaires l'instant d'après au moment
où il n'est plus il n'est plus all liser
alors qu'il s'était occupé de l'affaire
donc il faut vraiment qu'il y ait non
pas un mur au sens une cloison où les
gens ne puissent pas se parler mais qui
a une différenciation totale entre le
monde politique un peu aussi avec le
monde économique le monde aussi syndical
et associatif on peut pas être en même
temps par exemple président de
l'association et puis député parce que
il peut y avoir des conflits d'intérêts
on l'a vu avec l'affaire en on en a plus
plein comme ça aux États-Unis d'Amérique
c'est beaucoup plus clair et au
Parlement européen aussi on a vraiment
des lobis qui sont là qui sont destinés
à discuter en tant que for avoir un
petit un petit badge là comme le propose
les sénateurs ça peut apporter quelque
chose ça peut être quelque chose parce
que moi je vois bien dans les couloirs
de l'Assemblée il y a gens je connais
pas mais dont je soupçonne qu'ils le
sont et dans certains d'ailleurs ne se
cachent pas sur les incompatibilités
donc de certaines professions avec les
mandats parlementaires Gérard Larché dit
attention si un médecin peut plus parler
santé ou un éleveur agriculture on
risque un parlement en appesanteur
est-ce que vous êt d'accord il s'agit
pas de par il s'agit de savoir si on
peut continuer à exercer moi je crois
que le mandat de parlementaire député ou
sénateur c'est un mandat à plein temps
non seulement je le dis pour d'autres
métiers extérieurs à la politique mais
je le dis même pour les métiers
intérieurs je suis contre le cumulle des
mandats il y a des gens qui sont députés
Mair sénateur président de conseil
général mais comment font-ils ou bien
alors c'est les électeurs n'ont pas voté
pour lui ils ont voté simplement parce
qu'ils le connaissent puis c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui fait le boul à sa
place
alors mais je dis que il y a en effet un
parallèle entre le cumul des mandats et
d'une certaine manière l'ambigué entre
le fait d'exercer un métier à
l'extérieur dans un domaine économique
bien sûr et et et le fait d'être
parlementaire parlementaire c'est 100 %
et à ce moment-là on a du temps à
discuter avec les syndicats les
associations les forces économiques ça
c'est normal juste une petite question
les les deux assemblées travaill sur la
question chacune dans leur coin et au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs ce
sont les parlementaires qui vont décider
de leur propre statut vous êtes sûr
qu'on peut arriver réellement à à
quelque chose dans ces conditions B le
le le rapport de Monsieur Sauvet donne
des indications rapplyé qui et qui et
qui s'adresse pas au parlementaires oui
oui mais il est pas normal que les
parlementaires s'autosaisissent alors
les codes d' des autologies ça peut
exister mais ce qui est mieux c'est les
règlements intérieurs où là il est
indiqué très clairement c'est pas
simplement pour la procédure
parlementaire donc les parlementaires
peuvent s'autodiscipliner c'est possible
vous semblez en douter madame pas du
tout je vous pose la question ils sont
ils sont là pour faire la loi pour les
autres et pour eux-mêmes puisque la loi
s'applique à tout le monde il y a pas de
raison qui ne montre pas l'exemple et
qui soit même plus vertueux que
peut-être d'autres citoyens et bien on
verra on passe à la journée de jeudi
dans l'affaire du Médiator le
laboratoire Servier devant les
sénateurs c'est une première le
laboratoire Servier dépêche un de ses
responsables pour s'expliquer le
directeur scientifique du laboratoire
est auditionné ce jeudi par les
sénateurs de la mission d'information
sur le Médiator un responsable Guer
guerre bavare pardon Marie bremau je ne
répondrai pas à vos questions je viens
de répondre à la représentation
nationale j'ai donné toutes mes réponse
je vous remercie des vôtres mais je ne
peux pas répondre à cette question sans
avoir apporté un seul élément de réponse
le directeur scientifique de chez
Servier repart muré dans son silence son
audition était attendue dans le cadre de
la mission Parlement le médiat mais
durant 1 heure et dem face au sénateur
il ne lâchera rien pierre Chavi n'a rien
vu rien fait rien su ce n'est pas la
bonne personne écoutez vous posez
beaucoup de questions auquell
malheureusement je n'ai pas ni
compétence pour pour y répondre il y a
de jours Anne castau en charge de
l'évaluation du risque à l'Agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
produits de santé accepte-elle de
répondre aux interrogations mais les
explications sont Brou vague voire
incompréhensible quand on lui demande
pourquoi ne pas avoir retiré du marché
le Médiator dès les premiers cas suspect
on peut se poser des questions avoir des
suspicionss des préoccupations des
inquiétudes des
interrogation sans pour autant être
capable de comment dire établir et de
conforter ces interrogation qui n'ont
été conforté que bien après trouver les
raisons d'un si long surc du Médiator
les nombreuses alertes sur sa
dangerosité identifier les responsables
et leur part d'implication mettre en
exerg les failles d'un système de
surveillance la tâche s'annonce ardue
pour la mission
sénatoriale une première action
peut-être d'abord sur la la réticence du
laboratoire Servier à s'expliquer oui
c'est tout à fait stupéfiant d'entendre
le directeur général il faut d'ailleurs
remarquer que ça n'est pas monsieur
Servier lui-même qui est venu mais bon
évidemment un éminent membre de sa
direction va être entendu he par la
mission par j'espère bien euh oui alors
là aussi on parlait tout à l'heure de
conflit d'intérêt apparemment là aussi
il y a un énorme conflit d'intérêt mais
euh ça dépasse le laboratoire Servier
lui-même même si c'est un scandale parce
que le médiateur bon les fourchettes don
entre 500 et 2000 morts donc c'est très
grave euh mais ça montre bien disons
alors le poids des lobbyes
pharmaceutiques en France et en Europe
ils sont tout à fait considérables parce
qu'il y a pas évidemment que les
laboratoires servi donc j'espère que là
aussi il y aura quelque chose de plus
infranchissable entre les politiques
d'un côté et puis les laboratoires qui
ont droit d'exister de l'autre mais là
le pouvoir de Sarkozi est un petit peu
disons mis en cause puisque bon ça se
passe à nei il a été décoré par Sarkozy
enfin il y a vraiment une conivance et
donc il y a un conflit d'intérêt un
petit peu comme dans laaffire Bur où il
y avait un conflit d'intérêt entre être
à la fois trésorier de l'UMP ministre du
Budget et puis avoir par exemple sa
femme qui était au service de Madame
béancour et cetera donc donc là on voit
bien que là il faut des murs quoi il
faut vraiment qu'il y a une séparation
très claire pour que les gens puissent
discuter ensemble il faut faut pas qu'il
soit du même monde oui mais alors une
des pistes justement pour pour lafsaps
l'Agence du Médicament c'est qu'elle
soit financée non plus par les
laboratoires mais par l'État est-ce que
c'est réellement une garantie
d'indépendance en tout cas ça sera plus
fort que par les laboratoires parce
qu'on en est sûr que les rapports vont
être un petit peu biaisés mais je crois
que l'État lui-même alors l'état c'est
un peu difficile dire aussi des intérêts
à défendre bien entendu mais c'est
d'abord l'intérêt général c'est pas
simplement unintérêt industriel pour tel
ou tel nos champions nationaux mais ce
que je vois c'est qu'il y a trois
missions sur le médiat il y en a une du
président de la République enfin il a
dépêché je crois monsieur Debray he
justement par qu' une volonté de la bar
de circuité le travail parlementaire de
C mission oui parce que le travail
parlementaire il y a une mission
parlementaire du Sénat il y en a une je
crois avec Monsieur bapte à l'Assemblée
nationale et alors voilà que Monsieur
Debray le frère de l'autre Bernard
Debray et bien est missionné aussi mais
par le Président de la République bon ça
ça fait un peu je crois une manière de
noyer le poisson où on ne sera pas parce
que les conclusions seront pas les mêmes
et ça finira peut-être pas en que de
poisson j'espère mais c'est c'est il y a
quelque chose qui qui qui fait que
augmenter les soupçons plus on en fait
et plus les soupçons augmentent de la
part de nos concitoyens sur des choses
qui sont graves parce que la santé
publique c'est le poste numéro 1 de nos
inquiétudes allez on termine la semaine
avec la question du gaz de schiste
révolution énergétique pour les uns
scandale écologique pour les autres le
collectif sauvon les riches organisé
cette semaine un hing sur les
Champs-Élysées pour alerter la
population des dangers du gaz chisteux
jéréy
Hartman
ce forage là avait tout d'une farce
potach mais les sols français pourrai
bien être explorés pour de vrai dès les
prochains jours alors ce matin sur les
Champs-Élysées le collectif sauvons les
riches organisait un coup médiatique
devant l'hôtel Mariotte où des
industriel de la pétrochimie devait se
réunir objectif faire connaître au grand
public une mesure prise en toute
discrétion par Jean-Louis borlau avant
de quitter le ministère de l'écologie
autoriser les industriels à explorer le
sous-sol français il recellerlerait des
quantités non négligeables de pétrole et
de gaz de schiste Jean-Louis borlot
notre cher ami des écologistes a juste
avant de partir à signé 17 permis de
d'exploration des des gaz de schiste un
peu partout en France on s'aperçoit un
petit peu du double discours du
Gouvernement en la matière des forrages
très poants pour le paysage d'abord mais
aussi pour les Naves fréatiques ouais la
nouvelle de Paris
un peu d'eau potable après après après
fracturation du gaz voilà l'eau potable
c'est super l'humour pour mieux
vulgariser un sujet éminemment sérieux
cet après-midi à l'Assemblée plusieurs
députés de l'opposition ont exprimer
leur inquiétude sur ces forages sur le
banc du gouvernement c'est Natalie
cosossuscoorizet qui a remplacé
Jean-Louis borlau la ministre de
l'écologie se veut rassurant j'insiste
sur le fait qu'il s'agit bien
d'exploration et non pas d'exploitation
aujourd'hui II aucune autorisation de
travaux n'est délivré sur les permis
d'exploration de gaz de schiste
natthalie cuscooriset qui annonce
aujourd'hui la création d'une mission
pour évaluer les enjeux de
l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste on l'a pris jeudi donc le
gouvernement suspend les travaux de
prospection de gaz du gaz de schiste
est-ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle oui
pour le gaz de schiste ça n'est pas vrai
pour l'huile de schiste qui est plutôt
franilienne cette fois-ci mais on sait
quand on a vu la réalité américaine et
canadienne et bien que les les deux
techniques principales qui sont les
plies horizontaux les forages
horizontaux et puis la fracturation
hydraulique sont très impactantes pour
l'environnement alors bien sûr il y a un
peu de matière il y a du gaz où il y a
un peu d'huile un peu de pétrole mais
c'est tellement dur pour l'environnement
et ça dure tellement peu de temps car ça
monte comme ça on produit un petit peu
et hop ça redescend le déclin est très
rapide c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
sauver l'avenir énergétique de la
planète on va au contraire augmenter les
gaz à effet CRE il faut arrêter il n'y a
aucun moyen de de de d'avoir des
méthodes propres de d'extraction de ce
on connaissait ces gaz et pétrole de
chif depuis 1820 donc simplement du fait
que c'est très très dispersé ça n'est
pas les poches comme il y a pour le
pétrole ou le gaz classique c'est très
dispersé donc il faut tout casser en
dessous et les Naves fréatiques la
pollution de l'air est terrible y cocher
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous sur
ce plateau pour commenter la semaine
Delphine au revoir merci et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même lieu
même heure bonne semaine au
revoir